sur le fait que j'ai eu du mal à obtenir
des documents oui je le raconte un peu
dans le livre il ya un moment moi je
l'obtiens ces témoignages de deux
salariés de personnel soignant puis
après le directeur puis de jean après à
plus haut niveau au sein du groupe qui
me rapportent ces éléments c'est rfa et
cette optimisation de la masse salariale
c'est-à-dire un certain nombre de
directeurs se sont rendu compte au fur
et à mesure des temps et puis des gens
au plus haut placé qu'eux ils n'avaient
pas le nombre de postes auxquelles il
avait droit non ne pas se financer et
donc certains ont pris le risque avec
courage de me transmettre des documents
internes c'est à dire les
déclarations exactes la réalité de ce
qu'ils avaient dépensé en termes de
masse salariale d'otp sur les postes
financés par l'argent public pour
pouvoir
faire quelque chose faire parler ces
documents il fallait que je puisse les
comparer à ceux déclarés aux autorités
de contrôle et donc effectivement je
suis allé voir ce n'est pas ça a été
d'aller voir tous contacté un certain
nombre d' agences régionales de santé
notamment
la rs ile de france ou encore l' ars
aquitaine ses contacts et je leur ai dit
voilà je fais une enquête
sur le groupe orpea
et on me rapporte un certain nombre
d'irrégularités sur la gestion de
l'argent public
toutes les arrêts ce que j'ai contactés
ont refusé de rencontrer
m'ont dit que je n'avais pas droit
d'avoir accès à ces documents et m'ont
dissuadé d'aller au bout les discussions
étaient parfois tendues et moi je me
suis étonné que ces documents ne soient
pas publics que même un journaliste
depuis ce pas enquêter sur la question
j'ai eu le sentiment à plusieurs
reprises
d'être plutôt un effectivement un gêneur
qu'autre chose et pourtant je leur ai
expliqué plusieurs fois que mon enquête
elle permettait de comprendre s'il y
avait une mauvaise utilisation de
l'argent public donc elle était utile
pour les agences régionales de santé
mais je dois dire que j'ai été non
seulement très mal reçue mais qu'en plus
de ça j'ai appris que le groupe avait
été mise au courant de mes demandes
auprès des agences régionales de santé
gelée notamment a pris par l'ancienne
directrice de la communication du g2
cachons dans un mail qu'elle m'a
transmis où elle m'expliquait que
certaines ars
certaines autorités de contrôle s'était
plainte que je je demande à obtenir ces
documents que je sois si insistants donc
je me suis dit mince il ya des ya des
membres dares qui sont en contact étroit
avec le groupe et qui préviennent le
groupe de mon enquête et donc j'ai
commencé là à être
prudents dans la manière dont je
contactais les arrêts ce que je suis ici
à chaque fois que j'ai en contact et une
aile contacter le groupe
vaut mieux que je peux mieux vaut que je
fasse attention donc oui j'ai été très
surpris parce que j'avais l'impression
de faire une enquête qui était non
seulement de dire je le faisais pour les
familles et pour les salariés qu'ils
pouvaient être victime des agissements
de sous mais aussi pour l'argent public
et donc je dois dire gg pas compris et
mon éditeur n'a pas compris leur leurs
réactions et leurs attitudes et même le
fait qu'il refuse de me me rencontrer et
alors que quand j'ai rencontré notamment
certains inspecteurs du conseil
départemental de la gironde ils m'ont
dit tout de suite mais non écoutés
juridiquement on à droite vous
transmettre cerdd ses déclarations
annuelles on va vous les transmettre on
va vous laisser la possibilité
de vérifier ce que vous avez à vérifier
donc il y avait en tout cas une vision
très différente entre pour les ars
j'avais non seulement pas droit mais
j'étais je gênais et pour certains
conseils départementaux notamment celui
de la gironde et de la vienne j'étais le
bienvenu et là ils m'ont effectivement
transmis à des documents sur plusieurs
années les vrd pour plusieurs années
pour que je puisse contrôler 100
sans cette attitude j'aurais jamais pu
obtenir de preuves si j'avais passé deux
conseils départementaux qui m'avait
transmis
ces éléments
[Musique]